we continue this morning with our
promise to feature at least one new book
a week during the pandemic this morning
the bird way a fascinating look at
extremes and surprises from our friends
and the great outdoors the timing seems
right given the current crisis and our
collective hunger to see anything except
the couch but the book is also a
jumping-off point to examine a bigger
broader issue the state of billions of
birds overall there are plenty of
reasons for concern but also signs of
hope we spoke to conservationists
biologists hunters farmers and more all
of them birders this is still migratory
season so birds would be on the move
anyway but this year in the middle of a
pandemic as humans have retreated it
seems like the natural world is in
overdrive the morning chorus louder the
wildlife wilder there's no question that
people are being more observant and I
think it's cause for a lot of joy and a
lot of comfort Jennifer Ackerman is the
author of the new book the bird way why
do you think watching them right now for
so many people has been such a comfort
well for one thing they're the most
visible wildlife around us and they are
carrying on with their lives Ackerman
has been writing about science and
nature for three decades and her latest
work shares remarkable insights into
birds and those who study them that
includes former astronaut Jessica Muir
who raises geese from birth teaching
them to fly and even brave a wind tunnel
so she can better understand how they
handle extreme altitudes
there's the African Grey parrot
confounding widespread perceptions of
how birds behave by showing one giving
up its food for another it was this
really really remarkable show of
altruism in the bird world
and the unusual communication of the
great irani who cooperatively make
decisions with complete strangers to
raise their young this is an animal with
a brain that's about the size of a nut
and yet they have these strategies for
survival that are so ingenious really
should we still use the term bird brains
only as a complement birds may have more
open space in this current crisis but
overall they're hurting a much discussed
report in the journal Science this past
October said the bird population in
North America has declined by 3 billion
or 29% since 1970 there's so many
factors that are threatening them
climate change is a big one especially
with migratory birds and also loss of
habitat the work to protect those
habitats is ongoing two-thirds of the
endangered species in the world depend
on wetland habitats Wayne Roberts is
with Ducks Unlimited a group started by
hunters in 1937 to stop declines in
waterfowl populations it's now one of
the largest wetland conservation
organizations in the world oh yeah look
at her eggs beautiful she'll keep an eye
ball she's like you guys watch no we're
up - keep your distance
gentlemen we visited one of their
projects along one of the last and
largest remaining wetlands of coastal
Connecticut what are you trying to do in
areas like this we're gonna restore some
tidal flow into some of these areas to
treat the habitats the grasses and
things like that they're necessary for
the birds why are we losing birds the
theme that keeps coming up over and over
again is the habitat there's got to be
the habitat they gotta have somewhere to
eat somewhere to sleep somewhere to
breed you got to have a house they've
got to have a house
the work here is being done on Larry
Davis's farm the oldest continually
operating family farm in the nation
created in 1640 Davis is 13th generation
you've dedicated a good part of your
life to make sure this land doesn't get
built on ever all of my life grandfather
always preached keep the land then the
land will keep you I don't think that's
any more evident than today's academic
situation as a family farm as a farmer
we feed the world and if we don't
preserve it if we don't keep it and take
care of it they don't make anymore when
you hear about bird populations going
down and being thinned what do you think
I think that the environment is the
pulse of the world if there are bad
things going on if man has had too much
of an influence that has poorly affected
the world you'll find it first in nature
and so as bird populations drop other
species are as well
duck and geese populations bucking
historic trends have actually increased
in the last few decades it's imperative
that we as a race supposedly being at
the top of the food chain it's our
responsibility to preserve it are we
doing that right now to some degree yes
will we ever be able to do enough no I
don't think so with world populations
booming the way they are I don't know as
we'll ever be able to do enough but the
goal is for no net loss
lots of stuff going on right now like
larry davis jennifer Ackerman's passion
for the land and those who fly over it
is generational all of this started with
your dad that's right my dad he was a
huge influence in my life in this way
and we still share tremendous love of
birds and I'm forever grateful to him
for for setting me on this path for
ackerman and many others constantly
learning more about our most visible
neighbors it's the only way to make sure
they stay that way
we have made great strides in
understanding bird science but we have a
long way to go and I think particularly
in understanding how birds know things
and you know whether there are ways of
knowing in the bird world that are
different from our own we really have to
do what we can to make sure that our
children and our children's children get
to see the birds that we see and learn
from them and learn from they're still
you know largely mysterious ways Dana
the backyard has been going nuts this
year turkeys red foxes bobcats and the
wildest animal of all of course our
children keep them around the birds not
those other animals that you mentioned
you know I was thinking I've seen a lot
more birds out lately we've seen a lot
more animals to your point but I've seen
more and didn't even think about the
fact that just because we're seeing more
doesn't mean that they are out of the
woods when it comes to dwindling
populations and we do need to take care
of them beautiful stuff and you are a
bird brain I now say that with the
greatest respect thank you